uh so yeah it's our pleasure to have
alex demarcus from uc austin talking
today about how generative models are
the new sparsity so uh
please uh take it away alex thank you
thank you very much
so the title
uh is kind of a response to a previous
oh
to a previous talk that i will uh i will
explain uh the most important thing is
that this is joint work with uh with
many students including a jill who is
here is not here but we'll be here later
hopefully uh and
also janice
who is here uh she uh who is a postdoc
and she is in the job market this year
uh and uh faculty at ut john and eric
price
so
the story the joke here starts with the
title of the previous simons but when i
dig deeper i found a more interesting
story so in 2017
uh we wrote this paper with uh ashish
and agile who were phd students at the
time and eric price
and uh it's called compressed sensing
using generative models i will refer to
this as csgm throughout this long talk
so if you want to remember one acronym
so you don't like get lost immediately
it's csgm so i will explain what it is
but it's this paper
and basically we say that if you put a
again a generative other cell network as
a prior as opposed to sparsity you get
super good results in all universe
problems like denoising in painting and
a million other linear and non-linear
inverse problems and then soledad who
was a phd student of rachel at the time
at ut uh followed up and did some great
work on expanding this idea and she also
wrote the blog post that had this title
are generated generals are the new
sparsity question mark and here she just
shows for example that if you use a
generative friar you can denoise emini's
digits much much much better than you
would with sparsity-based techniques
that uh that use total variation in this
exam
so
then
in this
i don't know was it this specific
program or was it a different program is
this this program
i don't know if it's the same program it
was like a few weeks ago or
yeah okay so in this program then i saw
this title
and like arjuna advancing sparsity uh by
bruno and and uh you know it's the team
of florence and lenka who are working on
the the statistical physics uh uh types
of problems that arise in this setting
but i will explain so my talk is now
coming back and saying yes in case you
weren't worried they actually are
so i will explain of course what what
all this means so for the purposes of
this talk a generative
model is a function
that takes a k-dimensional vector that
we typically refer to as z as a latent
and produces a high-dimensional vector g
of z in rn rn is in the in the
experiments i will be showing we're
working with images that are 1024 by
1024 pixels so it's actually a million
dimension and it's actually a color
image so it's actually three million
dimension okay so we're going for five
500 dimensions to a million in the
experiments i will be showing and the
only two things you need to know about
this function is that there's matrix
multiplications and release here low
activations so it's a differentiable
almost everywhere function it's actually
piecewise linear
and it's data driven so you learn these
from samples so if as you're initially
training this and this is for a specific
way of training it that's called again
but i don't care about you knowing how
guns are trained
but you get you start getting things
like this in the first iterations and
then after a while you start getting
images like this this is already uh
2016-17 results so they look uh pretty
bad by now but they were they were state
of the art in 2016-17
and uh and uh you know i emphasize that
this is not a real person this is just a
dream as i say or a generated image or a
sample from this uh from this
distribution you can create a
distribution by putting gaussian id here
and the push forward sort of operator
here is creating a crazy distribution
that's actually k dimensional
in this rn um
ambient space right and there are many
of those gans va score base generators
and many others that i will be touching
a little bit about the details but for
now just think of all of them as a
function from z to g of z so
and then in 2017 or 18
these kinds of generated results came
out and i was thinking this are amazing
they pass the visual turing test we
cannot tell if these are real people or
generated images right
and this has been my main question in my
lab for uh for a long time model and
generative models produce amazing
pictures but what can we do with them so
one answer here is we can generate fake
pictures and fake social media linked
accounts and people do that but that's
kind of silly right and my point is
going from this idea where you you're
just generating totally fictional images
uh to this to convincing you on this
that they are modular and differentiable
priors that learn the statistics of your
data and then if you want to solve a
problem like an mri imaging problem or a
seismic imaging problem or or any uh
type of inverse problem actually it's
extremely valuable to have a pre-trained
generator
so
i will argue how you can solve all these
problems for example and you know we'll
start with in painting immediately
colorization is you know when you have a
black and white picture and you want to
complete the colors so it's like in
painting in the channels
uh and then uh i will talk about mri or
very recent work on mri
and uh actually people you see the
sparse pca here and i have deleted
sparse so you probably know uh what i'm
doing
like this has been done recently by
other researchers where they replace
sparsity
by uh in a range of generator as a
structural assumption
so uh the storyline is i will explain
how the csgm framework works
and
it's basically an unsupervised way to
solve inverse problems using a
pre-trained deep generative model
there is interesting theory uh if you
are familiar and if you have worked with
restricted isometric properties and the
compressed sensing theory where you can
get sample complexity bounds
there's a natural generalization of this
theory that i will talk about
uh it's basically
strictly isometric properties for sets
for the range of a generator
and then there is a some ongoing theory
that is appearing for inverting deep
generative models
because as i will say actually solving
the inverse problem requires solving a
non-convex optimization problem and
surprisingly there were results that
said that for a random generative model
the gradient descent provably solves it
if there is sufficient
i guess of a parameterization but it's
it's quite uh it's quite a reasonable
amount of parameterization as i will
explain
and the main real problem we had with
this whole line of work was that we are
actually limited by the expressive range
of the generator in practice so we could
not really apply this for real faces or
real images of mri because it was too
too biased towards what it has been
trained on
so the new work that is called
intermediate layer optimization that i
will talk about
uh expands the range of the generator
and it actually is able to match real
faces quite perfectly as i will show you
in a minute
and then we apply this to mri so i'll
talk briefly about mri applications and
fairness applications to this so we're
going to this kind of delay of the
of the land here
all right so immediately starting with
the the punch line so i was giving a
talk at michigan and this is vijay uh
who was my host uh at michigan so i went
to his website and downloaded his
photograph and i deleted this huge uh
chunk of pixels
and i'm going to show you how csgm
performs in this in painting problem
which is a linear inverse problem where
the matrix a we observe is a subset of
the identity rows
and it's also performing super
resolution here so we're going from 225
pixels to 1024
for free
so when my students run csgm we get this
result now a few things to look about
this
this is a a great photograph it's super
high resolution super crisp it knows
that people have two eyes and symmetric
mouths and so on so it's really good in
that sense
but it's actually a it's not vj right if
you know vj and i showed you this you'd
say
okay i see a similar but it's not really
the same person and more importantly
perhaps you see this is a white guy
right
whereas vj is not so you can see here
the the problems with the csgm framework
but also the power of the of the prior
that it is actually remarkably able to
to imagine all those missing pixels
uh but also it's it's imposing its own
uh biases here all right
and then with a more recent results so
if we do what's called intermediate
layer optimization if we do layers one
and two we get this result
and if we go even deeper and we optimize
layers one through four we get this
result i will explain what that means
but i'm just telling you the punch line
immediately so in this case you can see
that this picture indeed looks like
vijay is pretty
plausible it has a few artifacts that
you may notice if you look closely but
overall it's i think the one of the best
situations for for linear inverse
problems today so
just to set up the math now unless there
are any questions on this is all good
yeah okay and you know please do ask
questions much more fun so compress
sensing
or linear inverse problems we have an
unknown vector x star these are the
pixels of uh vijay's image that we want
to reconstruct we don't get to look at
it we get to see a matrix times x right
so
this is no it's called the measurement
matrix of the forward operator in
different
scientific communities
these are called the measurements
uh and of course this is like a linear
regression problem
you could have class noise if you want
but the biggest problem you have is that
the dimension of your vector is bigger
than the dimension of your measurements
right so you are you have to solve a nil
post problem here
and the standard the standard uh way
that people dealt with this is that you
assume x star has some structure
and the structural assumption that
everybody was assuming is that it is
sparse and now we're saying that we're
removing this assumption and we're
saying that x star is near or in the
range of a pre-trained generator like a
gan
and that's going to be our structural
assumption so that's that's why we say
that the generative moles are the newest
parts okay
so
this is all good and you can write this
linear inverse problems like this in
general
and this would be the very general form
of how you would solve you would try to
search find an image that explains the
measurements but also is natural right
and out of x is the regularizer that
prefers natural images
the classical
theory says
well natural images are sparse and l1 is
approximately l0 so let's just
regularize with l1 and hope for the best
uh and then if it is not sparse in the
normal basis you can also convert into
any other basis by a simple
transformation so lasso and dct or
wavelet domain is used quite a lot in
many many applications including mri in
production today
uh so
the the new idea is that sparsity is
good but
now we have data driven players like
deep generative models so we're going to
replace x's k sparse
with x's in the range of a pre-trained
generator
by the way uh recently uh actually in
shoeshred and eric price proved that
this is a proper generalization so
this is an interesting mathematical fact
uh they constructed the generative model
that has i think two layers
where only case bars vectors are
are generated by it okay so if you
assume that something is k-sparse it's a
special case of assuming it comes from a
pre-trained generator mode
uh so how do we solve inverse problems
yes sir
no no case bars in the case of zero has
k non zeros yeah yeah if l1 is is the
messy convex relaxation yes very good
yeah
so how do we solve inverse problems if
we assume x is in the range of a
generator it's pretty straightforward
so let's start with this so we take my
picture we have a pre-trained generator
okay so i want to emphasize this is an
expensive box we're using here style gun
2 which was trained by nvidia and spent
a lot of money and a lot of time
training this box i'm not going to mess
with the weights of the box okay the
weights are are nice the only thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to mess with
the latent vector and i'm going to say i
would like the latent output to match my
picture right how do i do that
i write down the loss so the way you do
anything in deep learning is you write
some function down into gradient descent
right so you start with a random z
you're going to generate a random face
now you say let's update z so that the
generated phase looks as much as
possible to my face right and you do
gradient descent because this is a
differentiable function of z because you
can back drop through g right so you do
gradient descent and you get this guy
now this guy kind of looks like me but
not really right maybe he's a little sad
uh
he doesn't exist okay so he won't be
offended or anything but but uh it's
it's it's actually a very good
high-resolution image it actually also
tries to match the background it doesn't
fully match it does a decent job but
it's not me and that's the problem of
the limited
expressive power of style gandhi it's
doing it a good effort but it's not
perfectly there
but beyond that
by the way we proposed this in 2017 and
many other people propose this
independently of us because it's a
pretty natural thing to do of course but
beyond that
now let's see how we solve an inverse
problem like this one in paid we're not
going to try to generate a person with a
huge black square we're going to say
i want a generated image after it has
been measured to agree with my
measurements right that's still a
differentiable function as long as the
forward operator is differentiable it
doesn't have to be linear all right
and in this case we've got this image
and again it's good but please notice
that the mouth for example doesn't
perfectly match because this image is
the best dream this this
gun could produce to sort of match these
measurements right
is this making sense all right
yeah
the forward operator can be any
differentiable forward operator because
the only thing this algorithm needs is
to be able to do back prop through
g and through a and through the
alternate so any forward parallel
differential ball works
yes
so is this all good all right and this
is all background that's why i'm going
fast this is our 2017 cs gmp
so if you have blurring again you can
write blurring as a matrix which is
convolving with a gaussian kernel for
example and it's actually exactly the
same algorithm but a now is no longer in
painting matrix it's a it's a blending
matrix and we get this this image these
are 2017 results that's why they look
low resolution here
so this is the csgm framework in general
na can be any differentiable corruption
process or forward operator
we do gradients and the latent space to
satisfy the measurements and we obtain
useful gradients through back
propagation
oh and the other thing is we are
leveraging the power of a pre-trained
generator that produces awesome pictures
but we're not just generating random
pictures we're generating we're tuning
it to match our pictures right that's
and that's the main point
so there are many other ways of solving
inverse problems if you care about them
i can't talk offline but this is a very
specific style of algorithms
now what happened now in 2017 was we got
this plot and this plot was saying the
generative methods are here what i have
here is number of measurements and this
is the quality of the reconstruction the
true quality of reconstruction right
because i have the ground truth and you
can see that you know we get this
quality whereas sparsity-based methods
need 10x like a thousand measurements so
that was kind of a punch line is you
actually can beat uh sparsity-based
priors by a factor of 10x uh if you use
genetic models but after this point kind
of flattens out and sparse the methods
actually beat you
and i have a question for you
why is this happening why is this flat
over here
we are increasing the capacity of
the generator
exactly fantastic so after this point
your problem is not that you don't have
more observations your problem is that
you have reached the representation
capability of your generator so as we
say in texas you need to throw away your
gown here and buy a bigger one right
so
the
at this point the you have basically
reached the best you can do and
you want to train another generator but
it's very expensive training on the
generator right
so at this point we have to find an
adaptive way of
growing the capacity of the generator
without training a million generators
you could do that but that's too painful
all right
so theory
i suppose this cloud cares about that a
lot so i should focus more but this is
the
previous theory results so you observe
linear measurements
assume you could solve this all right
first observation this is a non-convex
crazy style gun right this is a matrix
for now so now the theory only applies
for linear okay
so
uh this is an np-hard problem so it's a
non-conflict problem and we actually
proved with qi in a paper that for three
or more layers this is np hard to solve
exactly
but if you could solve it
if your measurement matrix a has random
gaussian measurements and the number of
measurements is k d log n where k is the
latent dimension
d is the depth of the generator and n is
the ambient dimension then the
reconstruction you get by solving this
is going to be very close to the best
possible reconstruction generator could
produce and then there is a plus an
additive term here actually because if
you have noise right so if you have
additive noise here you get this this is
optimal scaling you could hope to get
so the reconstruction accuracy relates
to your quality of your generator and
more generally the number of samples you
need is k log l well l is the lipstick
constant of the generator
so
the i don't know if this if people want
to
ask me questions about this the this is
kind of
the same style of result as uh
compressed sensing
and it is the kind of thing you could
hope for right it's it's uh it's
actually probably optimal within a
constant factor uh the number of the
dimension and l is the lipstick's
constant you can easily prove that the
ellipse's constant is always
like maximum weight to the depth so you
kind of go to this type of a result this
is from here right
no these types of phase do not
correspond to this we can prove random
independence this is like the classical
compress sensing case for for in
painting you would have to do another
analysis but it would depend also on
your generator it's not you need
incoherence between your generator range
and uh in painting yeah very good
all right so moving on the proof of this
is an rip property restricted isometric
property for the measurement matrix
so classically it says all sparse
vectors are far from the null space of
the measurement matrix that's what you
need to have rip right
and here it works out that the set
restricted eigenvalue condition that we
need for our a
is that
the differences of pairs of generated
images the differences of natural images
are far from the null space this is the
key technical condition you need it's
very natural if you worked in the space
uh like you know logic actually had this
sparsity which has structure which i
think is closely related was one of our
inspirations for this
uh so random matrices with so this is
kind of the the main dilemma here that
if you have k log l rows you will
satisfy strike with high probability and
this is one of the technical elements
now
uh
how it's proven is interesting because
we're trying to generalize it in the
other generators that have full
dimension full-dimensional support
the key idea is you want to make a good
coverage of this k dimensional manifold
in rn which is what the the generator is
creating
so
what you're actually saying is i'm going
to make an epsilon net in rk and every
one of my points
is transferred by a to so it's
transferred by g of z to the ambient
dimension but
the distances here can be distorted by
lipschitz constant in the worst case
so that's how i know how dense i need to
make it so that it is good enough
in the ambient dimension and i need to
union bound over all these points here
which is where i get the mk logo if you
know so the the m equals k logo
it's a union bound over this epsilon so
it's pretty standard technology
so this is the
metric entropy or the log covering
number of the generator manifold so to
speak and this will be useful to
generalize
now
optimization if you care about theory
for optimization you realize quickly
that this problem that i said you should
solve is actually np heart
and the story
for this was do you have a question oh
yeah
you're saying that the restricted
condition for gaussian matrices was not
proven before
no no it was proven it was proven but
for uh for not for the range it's not
sparse i'm not trying to recover a
sparse vector i'm trying to recover a
vector that's in the range of a
generator which is a neural network
okay so let's just improve it for uh
like a manifold yeah dimension
yeah so we proved it for a manifold it's
actually technically not exactly a
manual because it's the transformation
is piecewise differentiable only but
it's kind of a manifold and yes we
proved it for the set the the range of a
generator and the number of samples we
need
so these are the two results here sorry
is
uh this many so k is the latent
dimension of the generator d is the
depth of the generator and n is the
ambient dimension where it the generator
is going from k to n
okay yeah and
you say if a is normal random normal
with a result closer to what's reality b
if a is like sub-sampled fourier
so nobody has proved sample complexity
bounds for generative priors for fourier
as far as i know but but i think that i
don't know maybe agile knows this better
like is there any fourier results
yeah it's a natural it's a natural and
good open problem uh if you can so i
think you can also basically all the
compressed sensing and samples you can
see when it's when they generalize for
uh for uh generative
this is a very natural
strategy of questions that you can study
yes
but i i thought you said before that
like that this recent result that you've
got models positive like this also yeah
yeah i'm not i don't know the details of
exactly how they construct the generator
i don't think they've matched these are
not optimized in this sense yeah it's
not optimized at all in a sense but so
and also you cannot use it to do sparse
recovery because you could also use
their construction
in theory to reconstruct fast vectors
using uh the csgm technique but it sucks
yeah
okay so
uh you're basically looking at vectors
dz1 minus gt2 that's right and then uh
covering them with an epsilon net and
then showing that uh
you know
random [ __ ] measurements yeah
yeah it's like you do like a jl type of
a type of a bound for but then you do
union bound over the size of the epsilon
so it's a standard technology right yeah
yes
k is the the input dimension of the
generator so the generators
always are neural networks that go from
k to n so so it's a function this is g
of z
z is in rk sorry z and rk and g of z is
not n
right so this is the standard uh
terminology great
so
uh yeah so we did this
and
okay optimization now so this is as i
said how the heck are we going to solve
it
i mean in practice it works that's the
most important thing uh that we
discovered empirically
uh now for uh so pohan and vlad
waraninsky in this really interesting
paper in cold 2018
prove the following statement if the
generator has random independent
gaussian weights okay so fully random
generator
and every layer of the generator expands
so i hate the word expands because the
images of expanders and you know i love
expanders including theories this is not
expanders it's literally sometimes we
call it expansivity or something it's
like if the first layer is k i need the
second layer to be k times locate and
then i need the next layer to be k times
low k square all right so you need every
layer here to grow by a low k factor all
right
and they said
if your generator has this expansivity
of low k and has run weights remarkably
this non-convex optimization problem
with a random random instance of it will
have only two minima one at the correct
point and one at a very special point
that they can kind of exclude so a
variation of gradient descent that only
needs to avoid a bad local minimum
probably solves this problem
which i found quite a remarkable uh
technical achievement actually
uh so after that
so this was it's called
is the result making sense don't ask me
about the proof i still don't understand
i kind of hope hopefully do a little bit
but not really uh so but the result is
straightforward right what is what the
claim makes sense
all right then
uh you know we said
this is all good but if the weights are
random
and every layer is expanding
you can actually try to invert one layer
at a time so you're observing this
you can reconstruct this then you're
gonna construct this and you're gonna
construct this and it's it's not hard to
actually show that if this matrix is
expanding even with release in the
noiseless case you're getting noisy
you're getting half half of your things
are linear equations you can solve right
so if your expansion factor is two
or more you get enough linear equations
to solve one layer at a time and you can
handle noise too
so this is what this paper we had said
so we said you don't really need the log
k but we didn't have gradient descent
and then this paper by the skeletons
drove and zabatakis very recently said
oh i can actually get the paul hunt
gradient descent results for random
weights
but i don't need log k expansion every
layer i need constant expansion earlier
all right so they basically strengthened
as far as i understand the matrix
concentration that this paper is using
so
all this is great
but it's still open to do it for real
generators because real generators
almost always have a contracting layer
so near the end there's a layer that's
usually
like
64 by 64 but it has 512 channels so the
total number of parameters before you go
to the pixels is actually a contraction
so none of these results actually apply
it is open how to prove statements about
the optimization when one of your
generative model layers
has a contraction in it
i don't know that i don't know actually
if they have a lower bound so they say
it's impossible for random ones
you needed constant expansion but you
could maybe get rid of the branches
i think you certainly need constant is
you need some constant expansion for
sure
but i don't know
if there is if there is a caveat for one
layer contracting
so good point good point maybe maybe we
need more assumptions is basically what
yeah good so that's a state of affairs
as far as i know for the optimization
questions
uh and here is another result that uh
agile uh uh
okay i don't have the citation here so
this is a recent paper that studied the
following question so
generators like guns and vis have a
bounded lipschitz constant and the range
has a house of dimension at most k so
this is an interesting result that says
if you have a function from rk to rn
it could be full dimensional if it's
like some sort of fractal function but
if it has a bounded lipschitz constant
the range has a house of dimension at
most k so that's why we think of it as a
manifold
that has dimension k right
so the csgm theory says the number of
samples is basically k log n which is
all good but
some modern generators you may have
heard of invertible flows or score base
generators and so on have k equals n so
their their latent dimension there is no
latent dimension they're actually fully
dimensional they're supported on the
whole rn
but they're very concentrated
in some part of rm right
so how can we get a meaningful sample
complexity bound for solving inverse
problems when we have this fully
dimensional uh generator so that was
another question
and our answer is we define this thing
that we call approximate log covering
number or approximate metric entropy
uh which is saying the following thing
given a distribution p that's the
distribution where your images are
coming from
uh and some parameters the approximate
metric entropy is the smallest number of
balls you need not to cover all the
probability because you cannot cover all
the probability but to cover a one minus
delta fraction of the of the mass all
right
so with this definition so just to be
clear so for distribution p and two
parameters the covering number is the
smallest n such that there exists a set
containing n
balls of radius sigma in these are the
two balls so that you get one minus
delta fraction of the mass so you're
covering a decent fraction of the
support of the distribution so to speak
of the mass
and the theorem says that if you are
actually sampling from the posterior
distribution if you could sample from
the posterior
then you would get an error that is a
constant factor from the optimal error
you could get which is the noise
so this is saying that the correct
metric for all
inverse problems uh if you can sample
from the posterior is to sample from the
posterior
even if it's fully dimensional and this
is actually controlling the number of
samples you need the log covering number
of the distribution
and there's also a lower bound that
basically scales the same way so the
number of measurements
is some constant times the log covering
number which we call the approximate
metric entropy i haven't seen this exact
quantity defined anywhere so that's why
we called approximate metric entropy but
it's a natural kind of term in the
in the in this space if anybody knows of
other people defining
these types of measures let me know you
really need to cite some but
so
is this all good then i want to move
into the new algorithmic innovation
which is intermediate layer optimization
so we're going to optimize intermediate
layers to expand the range of our
generator and finally get my face
denoised and painted correctly
and i have
10 minutes okay good
so
uh i'm thinking of the generator like
here but now i'm going to take a knife
and i'm going to cut it in the middle
all right so i'm going to look at the
intermediate layer and i'm going to call
it h
okay
so this is still style gun 2. it still
has a z and a g of z but i'm i'm cutting
it in the middle and i'm looking at the
intermediate vector
and here's what i'm going to do
uh i'm thinking of it as a nested
generator like this g2 of h is g2 of g1
over z right so
uh
the first thing to do when you want to
invert an image or you want to denoise
is you run the csgm algorithm you search
in the latent space like before to match
the measurements
but after you do it
you're going to take a knife and you're
going to cut this out throw it away and
you're going to optimize this vector
directly okay effectively leaving the
range of the generator because not all
vectors here can be realized by previous
inputs
i'll show you in an example so
this is my image
and when i run csgm as we as you
remember we get this uh guy
now i'm going to start from this guy
corresponds to a z1 star right z1 star
produces this this phase
now i'm going to pass c1 star through g1
and i'm going to get an h and i'm going
to do gradient descent
from here to here starting crucially
from
this h that that came from this guy
and i get this image
now this image looks like me it's not me
i guarantee to you this image is a
generated image i'll show i think i have
it big yeah there it is do you see any
artifacts
so it's actually pretty close to perfect
i mean it doesn't match the background
it has a few artifacts here but it's
it's very very good so
this is the intermediate layer
optimization idea that says if you want
to
expand the range of your generator
just
treat it as a nested generator and
optimize intermediate layers now you
could ask me
hey what if i just threw away this thing
and i optimized directly in the space
it fails okay so how does it fail
it fails like this
see
so it produces this picasso
type of things
because it is the generator is too
powerful like if you're directly
optimizing this
you have too much expressivity you're
able to go beyond the range
way far from the manifold of natural
faces and and you're basically not
getting useful results if you want to do
art and make an nft
then and you know i and which i have
done
uh you can do that but if you want to
actually solve english problems uh you
should do this next i think that's what
we find is this making sense yes
how do you
choose yeah so
will you look better if you cut it
it's a hyperparameter thing what we do
is we do uh
10 steps or 10 to 100 steps of gradient
descent here then we do 10 to 100 steps
grain stand here and we go up to layer
four so you remember with the vj
image i started with we do 50 to 100
typically in each layer from layers one
to four if you go too deep you're
getting too expressive and you're going
to produce non-natural images
yes
exclusivity something you could solve by
like really stopping like in the deep
image papers they have the same
assurance the principle is too
expressive
that's fine we definitely do every
stopping also we we do in fact the hyper
parameters here is how many like the
number of iterations in each layer so
the way this is produced is you say
something like 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 and
you can go very deep or you can say 20
20. so you just do csgm and then 20
iterations in the next level so the it's
a the hyperparameter is how many
iterations you do in each layer of the
style gun
and yes we definitely need them to stop
good one yes sir
are there any heuristics i can use to
figure out how deep i should go or how
much to optimize each individual i would
love it if there were some theoretical
understanding or something i mean
the short sad answer is you try the way
you do any kind of parameter of magician
but if we had some principled ways of
doing this it would be great so there is
there is tuning that you need to do here
okay is there another question oh yes is
this related are these uh like all like
enchanting
yes so so this is an actual architecture
that's style gun too so it's actually
very complicated architecture so it does
it's not fully expanding in every layer
if that's what you're asking okay so
there's no relationship like it's an
extension like it doesn't have to happen
so this the current architecture does
not have full expansivity in every layer
for sure it's uh it's talking to is a
very complicated architecture uh but
if if we could design a new generator
that had full expansivity
maybe it would work better for this i
mean now it works pretty well but
it would be nice to have some more
understanding of how the architecture
relates right now i'm just searching by
hybrid parameter
yes this is actually what you just
answered but
it seems like what you did here you just
solve your problem by
getting a bigger generator by
cutting an existing generator to make it
bigger and then working around that so
if you could just get a go out and get a
bigger generator yeah would you need to
no
if you could get so for every number of
samples
there is an optimal expressivity of a
generator if you have very very few
samples you need a small k
because you you have to make a it's like
how many assumptions you make right yeah
yeah so if you have a ton of
observations you need a very expressive
generator so it doesn't have a lot of
bikes yeah so if i could pre-train many
generators at different expressivity
levels i wouldn't need this this is a
way that where we're getting many
generators from a single generator
but yeah it would be better if we were
tuning in okay so if nvidia can you were
doing this could they or
you could i mean
as you said you have many generators
here yes generators but they're not
trained as such right they're trained as
a single generator that's right
could you
i mean
so we could use other other sequences so
we are
if you did that did you think it still
needs to do
to regularize this uh generator yeah so
right the empirical results we get
are significantly outperforming any
other paper that uses any type of
generator for inverse from so we are
state of the arts in the in the uh so
maybe with bigger generators people
could could outperform us but empirical
performance we among any generative
techniques foreign response we're state
of the art here
so we don't know if any method of doing
better but yes if nvidia
trains some bigger family of generators
they could outperform i suppose
yes
any other questions of this so what do
you want to hear next you want to hear
fairness or i guess i have like five
minutes or something ah so just just
results quickly by the way this is a
real person this is a real press this is
the reverse so this is the phantom one
is a professor at stanford
we observe this
okay
if you saw this you wouldn't know it's
stefano okay in fact when when when and
also when you see this this is like i
think two percent random pixels
okay so from this
this is the result we get with ilo this
is the result that basically csgm
techniques get and this is the real
person okay and i would argue that this
is you know a good image
uh and this is a good image but if you
solve these two images and you know
stefano you would recognize the funnel
from this image but you would not
recognize the funnel from this much
right
so
and in fact i couldn't believe that we
were getting these results i asked jill
and my students to make sure they don't
have a bug in the code like 20 times and
our code is public but basically
performs shockingly well for these types
of roms you're able to reconstruct from
two percent of pixels or five percent of
pixels you can recognize a person so
it's it's shockingly good uh
of course we have tuned it but uh yeah
these are the results for
in painting the noising
and the blurring
so these are these are blurry images
these are previous state-of-the-art
techniques this is what we get you can
also see the bias here right and uh and
also this is obama
blair obama reconstructed obama which
was previous state of the art and this
is the super resolution ilo we get this
is uh the real ground truth
uh so i guess yes sir
of course we measure psnr and yeah of
course we have the ground truth
so we make plots of performance right so
so of course yeah so we make plots like
this so we put here psnr or there's also
perceptual metrics that we use s sim
uh is a perceptual method so there's
many distances we have ground truth we
have the reconstruction we just measure
it and we plot it as a function of
measurements so of course
now these results are for mri so i'll
quickly tell you i have five
no not really
one or two okay so we applied this on
mri the shocking thing i want to say is
that we were able to train a generator
on brains and still produce mri results
that are here's the punchline for mri
here
so
we trained the first generator for
clinical mri data
we use the facebook fmri data set we
match state-of-the-art for
in-distribution reconstruction methods
and we significantly outperform it when
the measurements change because we're
sub-sampling more we're trying to do
faster mri
or
when the anatomy change you can train
your gun on brains and then you try to
reconstruct a knee
it works pretty well if you do if you
have your generator that's expressive
enough
so we significantly outperform it and
then we have also done
a preliminary radiology evaluation where
we showed to three radiologists and they
evaluated in a blind way which
reconstructions are better for clinical
use so overall i think it's pretty it's
pretty uh promising i'm out of time so i
don't want to get into fairness but you
you remember the
the issue of fairness uh from is it the
data or is it the algorithm if you want
to know more ask me a question so i'll
take
time from my questions but the main
points
csgm solves inverse problems very well
but it's limited by the expressive range
of the generator
ilo expands the range by optimizing
intermediate layers we can get sample
complexity bounds assuming we could
solve this
and something from the posterior in
general which is a little different than
this using longevine is probably near
optimal and needs the low covering
number uh number of samples
and also gives you provable fairness
guarantees so i'll talk about this only
if you ask me and i have more time in
the questions
and interesting applications we are
working on applying it to mri and to
other imaging problems so that's the end
of my talk thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks alex for the really great talk um
let's take questions i'll hand you to
make a few
questions
so many
so maybe you could say a few words about
curry
oh who knew
okay so the story was that uh people
basically use this technique to do a
super resolution they uploaded you know
you upload this image you get this image
amazing right
and then somebody used their system and
they uploaded obama pixelated obama and
they got this guy and this guy is now
known if you if you google white obama
uh it's it's this it's this known fiasco
failure of uh of uh generative
techniques for solving super resolution
and the question is really this one so
i'll just
get to the punch line here
uh
is it a training data set problem that
the gam has seen more white people so it
produces more white people because
that's how it grew up with or is it an
algorithm and the answer we say is that
it's both okay so of course there is
bias in the data set but
the algorithm map inference is
amplifying bias
and the reason is so here's the simplest
example that i think crystallizes this
point here's again i flip a coin and i
tell you it's heads with probably 60
now i tell you guess
to maximize the probability you win you
do math what do you play do you play 60
heads
you always play heads right so if you
want to maximize the probability you are
correct even if there's a slight bias in
the data set
you are actually always going to go for
the majority class so your construction
algorithm is amplifying the
bias in the training date this was a
huge controversy on twitter and so on if
you follow this
and i think our answer is is do not
do much
instead
sample from the posterior so sample 60
head so in general sample p of x
condition on the measurements do not
which how do you get that you do our
algorithm gradient is sent in z but you
have noise it's longitudinal dynamics
like noisy gradient descent as opposed
to vanilla grain in the center
actually samples from the posterior if
somebody could prove larger in dynamics
was mixing polynomial time and all that
stuff that we cannot prove
but basically language dynamics is
trying to sample from the posterior
whereas csgm is trying to do map you
don't buy it you don't mind not it's
kind of because you're not going to know
it what's that i mean the mixing machine
loads is super slow right so i mean
you're stamping with it seems that
you're your problem is not like getting
the fuzz corrector on white obama so you
have two modes a black opal and a white
above anymore
but i have empirical results
[Laughter]
so yes it could fail it could fail yes
but it doesn't it's it doesn't so this
is the real this is real measurements
all right we have a paper right we have
a whole paper here that i didn't spoke
about but these are this is white obama
this is a sample from the posterior we
get from langevin dynamics
which is pretty good and you see that
this happens across the board so the
answer to your question is that could
happen indeed but gladly it doesn't
happen in our case because we tried it
we cannot prove it
but it would be really interesting to
analyze langevin the launch of an uh
flavor of what we're doing
uh perhaps let's say when the generator
has random weights so that's an open
problem that we're working on oh yes sir
sorry just just be clear but like that
would suggest that even if you ran
legible dynamics on like the pixelated
obama you would still get like white
obama some percentage at the time is
that true or do you always get like you
know real obama
that's an empirical question yeah yeah
so to to the that depends on how you
tune your generator but we don't get we
don't get yeah you could get something
in theory now in practice when we get
samples we could generate many samples
of this and i don't think anything looks
exactly like this because if you look
think of the distribution it i think i
think what's happening is the
distribution has something like this
there's a very spiky point here that's
white obama but if you're actually
sampling from a distribution you're
going to get samples here
you see what i'm saying so the
distribution can have very spiky points
uh that but that's what we believe is
happening in practice we can give you we
can we're going to run our algorithms
public
and you will not see why obama as a
sample you will see variations but it
doesn't get it doesn't produce that
picture
but it could be a hyperparameter
shooting issue
yeah other questions
so i guess we've had a lot of questions
throughout the talk so maybe we'll take
the rest offline all right and um let's
uh reconvene actually at 11 10. give
ourselves a little bit more time
[Applause]
oh